welcome back the british prime minister
boris johnson had a uh birthday party
during the first covert 19 lockdown in
june 2020 when social gatherings indoors
were banned according to itv news
a report from them in the last few
minutes mr johnson's office is quoted by
itv as saying in response a group of
staff working in number 10 that gathered
briefly in the cabinet room after a
meeting to wish the prime minister a
happy birthday took place he was there
for less than 10
minutes uh that report
from itv news uh boris johnson having a
birthday party during a lockdown
apparently our chief political
correspondent john craig joins me now
from
westminster john we're waiting to hear
from uh kia starmer and his reaction to
that but tell us more about these
reports
they're claiming that uh there was a
birthday party uh a a surprise
get-together on the afternoon of june
the 19th that's the prime minister's
birthday just after 2 p.m that was a
friday that day there was a news
conference uh
in downing street hosted by gavin
williamson who was then the uh education
secretary announcing that schools were
going back
at that time the rules were you could
have a gathering of six people outdoors
two people indoors now the um
ice this the number ten spokesman goes
on to say uh that uh itv news is saying
later that family friends were hosted
upstairs in the prime minister's flat
this is totally untrue number 10 is
saying in line with the rules at the
time the prime minister hosted a small
number of family members outside that
evening that's uh from uh number ten
i think we can have a listen to what kia
stammer is saying in response to that
this is yet more evidence that we've got
a prime minister who believes that the
rules that he made don't apply to him
and so we've got a prime minister and a
government to spend their whole time
mopping up sleaze and deceit
meanwhile millions of people are
struggling to pay their bills and we
can't afford to go on with this chaotic
rudderless government the prime minister
is a national distraction
he's got to go
it would be hard for the prime minister
to use the defense now that it was a
work event in this context
the prime minister has already used up
four different defenses to these
allegations
and all of them
point to prime minister is not being
honest
and
you know weeks and weeks now of
allegations weeks and weeks of deceit
from the prime minister meanwhile
millions of people struggling to pay
their bills
this is chaotic
it's rudderless and he's got to go
the prime minister has said repeatedly
previously all guidance was followed
completely in number 10. we have
followed the rules throughout i can tell
you once again i certainly broke no
rules
do you think he has lied to parliament
he started by saying there were no
parties
and all the rules were followed
then he said
ah there were parties i just found out
and i'm furious
then there was evidence that he'd gone
to a party and he said i didn't realize
it was a party and then last week he was
on the fourth defense which was nobody
told me it was against the rules and now
these allegations mean that all of that
can't possibly be true so do i think
he's been dishonest yes i do do i think
that he is a distraction when there are
real issues going on
in terms of energy bills cost of living
prices going up that people are very
concerned about complete and utter
distraction and that's why in the
national interest he's just got to go
so many party allegations now is sort of
almost hard to distinguish one from the
other
do you think it's possible for him to
hang on even to the end of sue gray's
report
he shouldn't hang on
i think the public have made their minds
up
i think public opinion has already
concluded that he broke the rules that
he made and that he hasn't told the
truth about it that means he hasn't got
the authority to lead the country when
we're in the middle of huge challenges
and therefore he has to go for the good
of the country
lying to parliament
always has been a resigning offence do
you think there is enough
evidence yet that that is what has
happened well i don't think that he has
told the truth about this i think the
public don't think he's told the truth
about this
any prime minister
who misleads parliament should resign
thank you very much great
kiestama they're reacting to these
latest reports john craig is still with
me so i mean boris johnson racking up
these parties or alleged
parties will sue grey do you think be
looking at this one
on his birthday
there are two allegations here one
about an event in the afternoon another
about one in the evening from on the
first one number 10 is offering an
explanation on the second a denial now
the first one according to itv news it's
alleged the pm's wife carrie johnson
helped organize a surprise get together
for him on the afternoon of 19th of june
just after 2pm now a surprise
get-together you could argue if it was a
surprise the prime minister wouldn't
have known about it what number 10 is
saying about that is that they gathered
a group of staff working in number 10
that they gathered briefly in the
cabinet room after a meeting to wish the
pm a happy birthday he was there for
less than 10 minutes now
uh the the itv report says up to 30
people attended the event in the cabinet
room after he returned from an official
visit to a school in hertfordshire itv
news understands the interior designer
lulu little not a member of number 10
staff also attended at the time she was
renovating the number 10 flat now the
second allegation itv news also
understands on the evening of the 19th
of june family friends were hosted
upstairs in the prime minister's
residence that's presumably the flat
above number 11 downing street in an
apparent further breach of the rules now
on that number 10 says this is totally
untrue in line with the rules at the
time the pm hosted a small number of
family members outside that evening the
number 10 spokesman added now the rules
at the time were six people outdoors
number 10 not saying exactly how many
were there but it says
a small number of family members outside
so two allegations one there's an
explanation the other there is a denial